cet enfant a une structure cérébrale
tafer unis
une nouvelle forme de génie
[Musique]
nous voulons tous savoir ce que pensent
ou ressentent les gens
cela signifie kellock nous pourrions
accéder aux pensées au souvenir d'un
sujet mais qu'est ce que ça nous apporte
vous voulez piraté le cerveau humain est
ce que tu as vu
[Musique]
j'ai vu quelque chose
vous êtes encore suspect dans une
affaire de meurtre
différents souvenirs se mélangent dans
ma tête et je ne peux pas les trier
qu'est ce que vous voulez savoir sur
votre fils
donc vous avez les souvenirs de thunes
game dans votre tête
souvenirs auquel il a accédé
était déformé extrêmement
je sais plus aujourd'hui